hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Dan
Seibert we're gonna watch the cinematic
trailer for a game called overwatch okay
how hands up front the Tweety Bird has
seen the overwatch trailer already all
of my friends when Blizzard announced
this thing was like Dan overwatch sign
up for the beta and I want all of you to
sign up for the beta so we can all play
on the beta together I want to play on
the beta once playing the beta with
everybody with you you'll play but I'll
play with you too you know I mean it's
like if I can count on I guess
permission to play with you oh thanks
chip
alright acceptable may contain [ __ ]
inappropriate visual and
it's so good
conflict as the world teetered on the
brink of anarchy
a new hope arose an elite international
task force charged with ending the war
and restoring Liberty to all nations
overwatch soldiers how scientists
adventurers oddities Guardians who
secured global peace for a generation
under its steadfast protection the world
recovered and today though its watches
and its soaring ideals of freedom and
equality will never be forgotten that
was so cool in that one battle they had
sound weak remember he has like actually
no no tracer yeah tracer she's like
she's no the Cavalry's here
sweet can I remind you the Incredibles
right yeah it looks just like it
thank you gauntlet oh man they say he
could level the skyscraper and remember
he was all fighting and with Cynthia and
it was like that's only in all of it
everybody knows overwatch got shut down
half of them are just mercenaries now
join me all right play times over get
the cover by the cast
Sam yeah but I love it
ha
oh my god yeah actual ability music in
the game oh wow how are they
come on big guy yeah
Oh
stay here
it says beautiful direction right yeah
hey nice
hell yes
you know the world could always use more
heroes
yeah awesome
right that deserves an applause is so
[ __ ] good
that dude whoa holy [ __ ] I got an F dude
that was amazing
it's its own like it's a short film it's
a it was you know I've said like other
ones before on games like this should be
a movie and I've heard cinematic trailer
a billion times oh yeah you don't
realize this as a video game like no no
no it's capped it looks like one of them
like big hero six or a Pixar movie it
looks just like one in Italy it was like
one it's got the emotion like I was
actually a little inspired when she said
the world needs more heroes
I was like yeah they do need I could be
here oh cool nice neat it's like the
teenage like the teenage kid has like
his whole like through life like he goes
from like this is so dumb to like I got
a stand-up and then suddenly it's just
like yeah maybe the world does need more
here so it's like a whole [ __ ] like
emotional story is my emotional
storyline to it the heroes are [ __ ]
cool do you gotta just talk about like
there's no game playing is but you got
to talk about just like what the [ __ ] we
just saw there's so much in beautiful
direction in that it was from the
beginning I was like this kind of looks
like The Incredibles and then the action
started going and I'm like only an
animation can be directed like this oh
yeah and pull it off this well I can be
that believable it's so good and the
gameplay by the way you seen some
gameplay I've seen some gameplay I seen
any of course I have some friends that
went to VidCon or not VidCon uh Blizzcon
totally different con but they got a try
it and I said it was amazing wow it
looks incredible the voices are cool the
[ __ ] like the powers are neat to see
action was so [ __ ] cool like I feel
like a little boy watching this right I
had like a boy wonder about it you know
and they showed like the best part is
they show half of the abilities that
those characters can use you're like
deaths doing is like whole like cloud of
like shooting all those guys really dude
that's awesome I wish I could do that in
the game oh wait I can I feel like they
can take the cinematic footage and then
just turn that into like a movie itself
I'd be okay yeah I be I'd be okay if
they just turned like they just like
animated the
gameplay stuff into a movie sequence I
think you could get a legit movie out of
it I think fans will love that too the
combination of new footage combined with
the original footage from the game like
that be so [ __ ] neat but you'd get the
opportunity to like you go watch the
movie that actor was like I want to keep
living it oh wait I could go home I
couldn't play I mean the fact that it
was like the animation made it feel more
like it's weird because you know they
got games like Metal Gear Solid and
Assassin's Creed that always have these
cinema trailers with this one it was
like for some reason this felt like the
most cinematic trailer I've ever seen oh
absolutely that was great that was
fantastic
[ __ ] you're right you can just show this
to people who are not into games and
they get a good short film out of it you
don't even have to know you like you'd
be a surprise at Dan you're like oh wait
this is a video game yeah it's just a
great short film overall like that was
fantastic anyway guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects where there's so much [ __ ]
you might not even care to check out the
channel and dance cyber has a channel to
a gaming channel where he talks about
games so what do you think is here for a
game reaction games that cyber channel
gaming a play stuff check that out also
on my channel smash week I'm part of it
too yeah I'm part of this match week
smash week smash bros all week leading
up to the wii u version that plays we
played the n64 version yep it dominated
Louis Jones - Oh a big dick give me a
shout out on your next video also tell
Samantha she has a nicest face from me I
love all the [ __ ] that you do keep it up
you [ __ ] Lewis Jones I don't know
why you're such an [ __ ] but you
talked about dick and I like talking
about a good dick you know what I mean
everyone's got their [ __ ] and here
our [ __ ] your [ __ ] you're one of
our [ __ ] Louise you wait we have
multiple yeah we should probably get
that checked out yeah I don't know it
actually helps clean out the system a
lot better you know and me I'm faster to
get more out um it Luke Jones you can
have a shout-out I'll make sure to tell
Samantha that you jack off to her okay
star bits master hey Ryan
long time no see anyway I would love if
you give me a shout-out since I have
been supporting you for a while
thanks star bits master you are the
master of the stars no wait that is our
Lord and Savior Jesus you must be the
Antichrist
what do you think you're doing on our
channel double question if it's star
bits is it Super Mario Galaxy
that might be a little more
accurate than the theory hi John - I'm
just like star bits master the must be
super mario galaxy yeah I somehow got
Antichrist from Dan with the dead ant
dead ant of the day dead nenenene
dad at the pageant who wouldn't want to
subscribe to dams channel [ __ ]
Adrian sharee sup shout-out please
Adrian sharee you did not give any
specifics except you wanted us to watch
the 50 Grey's ship dish but you wanted
us to watch the fifty Shades of Grey
trailer which uh yeah that should be up
by now
I'll try to give you a shout-out um
Adrian sharee I mean what does that
sound like to you it sounds like it
sounds like a kind of Satan worshipping
thing what's up with all the scene in
this today on the channel you know I
thought about what I hear at Adrian I'm
like ah Adrian Peterson
I hear ya yo a jury which do with it
don't know what yo Adrian Adrian over
dude that's my soul that's just almost
pretty close yeah duper me a little less
I clear like entitles a bunch of eating
a meatball
um that's a Trenton we got we we do the
wrong the whole time instead of that
that